und meine kollegin angelique bereich
steht vor dem brandenburger tor
wir waren auch dort einmal hinschauen
wie dort die stimmung ist uns dann
einige bilder erreicht von wirklich
aufgeheizter stimmung
angelique was kannst du uns berichten
wir stehen jetzt mittlerweile nicht mehr
vor dem brandenburger tor wir sind auch
richtung friedrichstraße gelaufen mit
dem strom mit der masse der menschen die
mein kollege schon gesagt hat es sind
weit mehr als 30.000 menschen
auch hier hat man jetzt entschieden sich
einfach mal hinzusetzen vielleicht
können wir mal können wir mal zeigen die
sich die menschen jetzt hier hingesetzt
haben wenn die kamera einschränken
könnte
auch hier ist kein kein durchkommen mehr
die stimmung ist gut hier man kann
nichts anderes sagen die leute rufen
nach widerstand nach freiheit aber auch
wie peter gesagt hat hier geht es
eigentlich nicht mehr so richtig und
bewohner sondern hier wird über alles
andere diskutiert nachdem nach der
freiheit nach widerstand über bill gates
und über über die jüdische
weltverschwörung also ist wirklich
vielfältig was die leute hier auch die
straße treibt und wir haben es schon
angesprochen ab jetzt geht ja eigentlich
auch wir haben gehört dass ist
wollen hier die leute müssen jetzt hier
bleiben an dieser stelle ist geht es ist
also kein durchkommen mehr wir kommen
jetzt auf grad nicht weiter wir haben
schon angesprochen mittlerweile müssten
die leute eigentlich masken tragen und
die abstände einhalten
das funktioniert nicht wirklich und wir
wollen jetzt auch einfach mal fragen was
denn die leute davon halten
darf ich sie mal fragen jetzt wurde ja
beschlossen dass sie eigentlich die
demonstranten masken tragen
sie ist ohne maske und hat keine dabei
ich bin also dass renault abständen
hätten ja und keine machen
jetzt wurde aber beschlossen dass die
maske eigentlich pflicht ist
ich habe langsam dieses hin und her
wirklich satt und für mich hat diese
politik jede glaubwürdigkeit verloren
jede allein dieses rumgeeiere mit dem
verbot warum akzeptieren die nicht dass
wir hier einen demonstrationsrecht haben
warum wir können warum sind sie hier
heute auf der straße gegen wasser dafür
dass demonstrieren geeigneten
weil auf die straße gehen das einzige
mittel was ich noch habe in dieser
angeblichen demokratie ich kann nicht
warten bis ich mal wieder ein kreuzchen
auf dem zettel machen darum das was
gerade passiert ist ungeheuerlich
es werden grundrechte abgeschafft und
die machen das mit einer
selbstverständlichkeit dass ich mir die
haare sträuben und deswegen bin ich hier
dankeschön
wir hören also was die leute auf die
straße treibt ist das angeblich keine
freiheit hier herrscht dass die grund
gilt das grundgesetz eingeschränkt wird
es gibt aber auch noch viel viel
bruderer theorien aber man kann sagen
also es ist festzuhalten
hier wo wir stehen im moment ist es
wirklich friedlich die leute haben sich
hingesetzt und man weiß jetzt nicht so
recht was man machen soll weil es kein
durchkommen mehr gibt
meine kollegin angelique ära live von
der demonstration in der hauptstadt
vielen herzlichen dank